Le million d’euros !
2 millions, mec !
Voilà !
C’est une énorme occasion,
que pendant trois jours
se défoncer
pour une belle œuvre caritative et,
honnêtement, ça fait plaisir,
ça fait du bien.
Let’s go !
Vous êtes incroyables.
10 000 balles !
La communauté est incroyable,
cette année, incroyable.
Merci beaucoup
Eterlou pour les 7 euros,
merci beaucoup Simfury…
Let’s go !
C’est maintenant !
Il va falloir continuer.
Ben là, l’événement,
ça donne la meilleure image du streaming.
Je déclare Z Event 2021 ouvert !
Merci à tous !
Ça y est, le Z Event vient tout juste d’être lancé,
les streameurs sont passés en live sur Twitch
et leur objectif,
ça va être pendant les deux prochains jours de lever
le plus d’argent possible pour Action contre la faim.
Mesdames et messieurs, bienvenue au Z Event,
installez-vous confortablement,
nous allons décoller pour des donations.
Merci, Fraga, pour tes 14,93 €.
1000 euros bordel.
J’ai mon premier don de 1000 euros.
Oh là là !
Ce qu’il faut savoir, c’est que tous les streameurs
ont ce qu’on appelle un donation goal,
ça veut dire un objectif de dons,
et à chaque fois, ce sont des paliers, ça peut être
10 000 euros, 50 000 euros, 100 000 euros,
voire beaucoup plus pour certains,
et dès qu’ils passent ces paliers, ils ont un gage
ou ils doivent faire une action.
Là, moi, j’avais un donation goal à 5000
où je devais me changer en costume de surprise, quoi.
Ça tiendra jamais.
Pour ce Z Event, je serai votre princesse.
Tous les 1000 euros qu’on passe,
je vais avec ça et je dis :
“Fais-moi un petit dessin dans le crâne.”
C’est un peu bizarre, hein.
200 000 euros, on fait Paris-Marseille à pied,
les reufs. 50 000, je boxe avec Sardoche.
Pierre qui donne 7 euros pour les gens dans le besoin.
Donc là, les gars, ouais,
c’est Action contre la faim, l’association.
*Sirène*
Excusez-moi de vous déranger.
Annonce assez importante : c’était pas arrivé depuis assez longtemps,
mais vous avez fait planter le module de donations,
merci à tous !
En gros, moi, je suis en communication avec Streamlabs.
Streamlabs, c’est notre partenaire, qui récupère les dons avant que ça passe par d’autres plateformes
pour aller dans la cagnotte de l’asso.
Et donc, il y a un module de don alloué
et on l’a déjà fait sauter en…
30 minutes.
Ça veut dire qu’il y a tellement de connexions et de gens qui font des dons
que la charge serveur est pas prise par le site
et que, du coup, tout explose
et plus rien ne marche. Voilà.
Maintenant, c’est la merde,
mais on va essayer de régler ça !
Je pense que ça va le faire.
- La cagnotte, elle remarche.
- Les gars, ça remarche, vous pouvez y aller.
Vous pouvez y aller, vous pouvez y aller !
1000 baaalles !!
20 000 euros ?
Mec, j’ai compté les zéros pour vérifier
que c’était le bon chiffre.
Là, pour vous donner un ordre d’idée :
quasiment toutes les demi-heures, ils passent un palier de 100 000 euros,
c’est complètement dingue,
ça va très, très vite.
- Bon, bah on va se baigner, hein.
- Allez !
Ciao ! Je vais me baigner !
Donc là, on va direct sur la plage.
Là, il y a le port, à droite, donc c’est le port de Bora-Bora.
Tout va bien se passer, c’est fait par des professionnels.
Ouah ! Elle est chaude, hein !
Elle est très chaude !
Il est dedans, il est dedans !
Ah oui, on voit les vagues.
Wouh !
700 000 euros !
Donc là, tout le long du week-end,
ils vont faire des jeux tous ensemble.
Par exemple, là, ils sont en train de jouer à Fall Guys
et l’objectif, c’est d’être le dernier survivant.
- Et cassez-vous, putain !
Mais putain !!
Mais oui, je suis mort, évidemment !
Aaah !
Le final qui oppose Antoine Daniel
et Domingo sur les hexagones.
Qui va craquer ?
Oui, mec ! Boum !
- Aaah !
Antoine Daniel !
Let’s go !
La salle est en train de se transformer
en cour de récré géante, c’est énorme.
Ici, opération buisson.
Je répète, nous sommes dans la pampa.
Je n’arrive pas à savoir qui est là-dessous.
Ah putain ! C’est Alex !
Tu vois ? Tu vois ? Tu vois ?
Tu vois, ou pas ?
Vas-y !
Rome ! Rome ! Rome !
Attends. Je suis en train de changer…
Eh tu vas couper le stream.
10 000 balles !
Pokimane, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe !
1000 balles, Milouf !
Ils sont à deux doigts de passer le million d’euro
récolté dès le premier soir
alors que l’année dernière, c’était le samedi à 19h30.
Donc clairement,
ils sont en train de battre un énorme record.
Vous êtes des boss, les gars. 1 euro ! 1 euro !
Merci à tous ceux qui donnent.
- Allez les gars !
- Faut contribuer au million.
Allez, encore un petit effort !
Allez, allez, allez ! Plus que 200, plus que 200 !
On y est presque, on y est presque, le million !
Le million d’euros !
C’est le million !
Là, il y a un truc très marrant qui va se passer
juste derrière moi dans ce ring.
En fait, il y a Morgan Charrière,
qui est un combattant professionnel de MMA,
qui est venu pour affronter Kameto, un streameur,
sauf que Kameto n’est pas du tout au courant.
Ils pourront pas nous tanker.
Tant qu’eux ne nous atteignent pas, c’est game.
Il va se douter de rien. Il va être comme ça : “Ah !”
Ouech, le Kam. Ouech, le Kam !
Il est mort ! Il est foutu ! Il est foutu !
Casse-lui la gueule !
Ouech, le ring, il est petit, quand même.
Je lui mettrai des coups dans le front,
ne vous inquiétez pas.
3… 2… 1… Hajime.
Waouh !
Oh là là là là là…
Ouais, Kamel ! Ouais, Kamel !
Tiens, tiens, tiens !
Allez, Kamel !
La garde, la garde !
40 secondes, Kamel, allez !
40 secondes !
C’est fini !
Regarde pas la cam’, regarde pas.
J’ai gagné, non ?
J’ai gagné.
Ouais !
Ça a fait “dring dring”, j’ai vu le poing, il était déjà là.
À un moment, j’ai essayé de mettre des coups,
j’ai vu, il n’y avait aucuns dégâts.
C’est la fin de la première soirée, il y a déjà beaucoup de streameurs qui sont partis se coucher.
Même s’il y en a quelques-uns qui vont rester
pour assurer le marathon,
la plupart veulent garder des forces,
parce que c’est demain
que les choses sérieuses commencent.
Les deux sont prêtes.
Je te le fais manger pour pas que tu…
Puisque, après,
si tu te touches des yeux sans faire exprès…
Allez, vas-y.
OK. T’es bon ?
Ah, ça brûle.
Vas-y, vas-y, croque.
T’as vu ? Ça met un petit punch.
Mais… les goûts, les saveurs… Apprécie !
Il y a rien, gros.
Oh.
Ça passe, un peu, non ?
Ça va ?
Non mais attends, c’est de pire en pire, là.
Ah ouais ?
Ça va aller, mais c’est là, en fait, c’est… C’est…
En fait, quand je bois ton truc, je suis bien,
mais quand je l’ai plus, c’est pas bien.
Oh, quel plaisir !
Les gens ont tendance à sucer les piments au piquant
alors qu’il y a un goût derrière tout ça.
Eh oui. Il ne faut pas s’arrêter aux épines.
Tous les ans, il y a un peu les vétérans
qui reviennent à chaque édition.
Il y a à chaque fois mistermv en général,
MoMaN, Alphacast, Jiraya, Domingo,
Gotaga qui revient très souvent, Maghla…
Et il y a aussi beaucoup de nouveaux cette année,
notamment RebeuDeter et Amine qui cartonnent
en ce moment sur Twitch avec des live,
notamment en extérieur.
Donc, je ne sais pas du tout ce
qu’ils ont prévu cette année,
mais à mon avis, ils ont l’air très chauds,
donc ils vont faire pas mal de conneries.
Oh, Michou !
Ça va ?
T’as dit quoi ? Ça va ? Merci pour l’invite.
Mec, je suis trop content d’être là.
En vrai, première année que je le fais.
Déjà, j’ai vu l’invite, j’étais refait.
Donc là, objectif, c’est de mettre le feu.
On va s’amuser.
Je suis prêt à donner 200 balles dans la cagnotte
là maintenant si,
à vous deux, vous faites 100 tours sur vous-mêmes
en moins de, genre, 5 minutes.
Pour 200 euros ? Mais bien sûr !
- 1… 2… 3 !
- Je compte, je compte.
1, 2, 3, 4…
100, on a dit 100 !
C’est dur ! La tête de oim, c’est dur.
Continue !
30...
31...
32...
33...
49… 50… Pause, pause.
Repose-toi, repose-toi, repose-toi.
Ils sont où, les dons ? Ils sont où, les dons, là ?
OK. Là, il y a des gens qui sont un peu arrivés,
j’ai des nouvelles victimes à aller flash.
Ah, mais c’est Deujna, la tête de oim,
je savais pas c’était quoi.
C’est trop dar, l’ambiance qu’il y a ici,
avec tous les streameurs,
tu peux parler avec tout le monde,
tout le monde est du même game et tout,
c’est de la frappe, frappe de ouf.
J’avais déjà rencontré, genre, deux, trois personnes et là,
j’ai pu en rencontrer une trentaine de plus.
C’est l’occasion de se troller, de se taquiner en vrai, etc.
et autre que derrière un écran et ça fait vraiment plaisir.
Merci FK pour les 1 euro.
Merci Rudin, merci Ria, merci Magalie pour les 7 euros.
Merci Yoda pour les 5 euros.
Merci à ÀDécouvert pour les 1 euro.
1 million 990 mille, on y va, on y va, on y va !
On est samedi soir, il est 19h30 et les dons
sont en train de monter très, très, très vite.
Ils vont passer les 2 millions d’euros.
Merci, on va les atteindre, ces 2 millions.
Il reste quasiment 10 000 euros.
C’est fait !
2 millions d’euroooos !
2 millions, mec.
Je me concentre juste sur ce
que je dois faire dans ma tête,
c’est-à-dire arrêter de bouger comme une merde,
pas couper la parole à Samuel, être heureux.
Moi, je suis en panique, ça va être compliqué, là.
La capitale de la France : Paris.
Comme pour l’édition précédente, cette année
il y a le journaliste et présentateur Samuel Étienne,
qui a percé depuis à peu près 1 an sur Twitch,
qui est venu pour présenter une émission
qui s’appelle Question pour un streameur.
Question pour un streameur 2,
c’est extrêmement simple.
Qu’est-ce que c’est ?
C’est un quiz de culture générale en trois parties. OK ?
Préparé par Étoiles.
Quelle est la capitale du Sri Lanka ?
Sri Jayawardenapura Kotte ?
- Oui ! Oui !
- C’est trop !
Ah, mais c’est toi qui présente
Questions pour un champion.
- C’est sérieux ?
En fait, quand je m’ennuies sur Twitch,
je vais à France 3 et j’anime un…
Oui, je me rappelle, je me disais bien que je l’avais vu,
franchement, mais je me suis dit :
est-ce que je le dis ou pas ?
Je fais mes études à la haute école de musique de Varsovie avant de quitter la Pologne à 21 ans. Pianiste…
*Buzzer*
- Chopin.
- Oui.
C’est ça, c’est ça !
Bravo !
Let’s go !
Champions de l’édition 2021 de Question pour un streameur 2 : Antoine Daniel et Ponce.
Le Z Event et les streameurs et papy Sam,
quand il streame,
touchent un public qui n’est pas forcément
sur les médias traditionnels.
Passer des messages positifs comme la solidarité,
la lutte contre la pauvreté
avec Action contre la faim,
c’est hyper puissant, quoi.
Donnez des dons, dans la description,
vous pouvez y aller.
Allez, les 1 euro, les gars,
comme l’a dit Michou, il faut revenir.
On a commencé à lancer l’appel aux dons,
c’est monté ultra-vite.
On l’a fait ! On l’a fait en même pas 35 minutes !
Vous avez explosé 50 000 euros en 35 minutes !
C’est monstrueux, ce qui est en train de se passer !
Venez, on ne dit plus rien jusqu’à la fin.
Voilà !
150 000 !
Tout le monde va sur le live de Michou !
On est sur une bonne lancée.
C’est maintenant, il va falloir continuer.
Quel va être le premier prix qui va tomber,
vous avez 5 minutes,
messieurs-dames, vous avez 5 minutes
pour ce magnifique, magnifique tableau.
350 balles chez Cocolane, juste ici !
1000 balles, Gimji !
Adjugé, vendu pour Creiss, 1708 euros !
1708 euros.
Les anciens ont hyper bien intégré les nouveaux et
ont fait un truc que moi, je trouve vraiment exceptionnel,
ils ont été hyper créatifs cette année,
ils se sont tous super entraidés, ils ont tous participé
aux trucs les uns des autres,
alors que parfois, ils ne se connaissent pas tant que ça
et c’est un peu le but de l’événement,
c’est de créer des featuring inattendus.
Je pensais pas que j’accrocherais autant
avec certaines personnes et tout et je sais que,
une fois l’événement fini, j’aurai qu’une envie, c’est,
dans les semaines et mois suivants, faire des trucs,
des projets avec ces personnes-là.
Là, la plupart des streameurs sont partis se coucher
parce qu’il est 4h30 du matin,
mais il y a un petit groupe d’irréductibles
qui a décidé de lancer un karaoké.
Le karaoké vient de se terminer,
c’est que maintenant que ça commence
à se calmer un peu dans la salle.
Il y a toujours une période de flottement
où on est entre 5 et 10 et
c’est le moment que j’adore au Z Event,
parce que c’est calme, en fait.
J’ai plus l’âge, moi, de foutre le bordel.
Le matin, la nuit, c’est chez moi, c’est…
Pour vous, c’est la nuit, pour moi,
c’est le début d’après-midi.
Jump sur lui, jump sur lui, jump sur lui.
Viens, on s’en va.
Genre on s’en va loin.
Ah non, mais attendez,
il y a un autre streameur, là-bas.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’il fait ?
C’est sûr qu’il a l’air bien.
Je pense que c’est vraiment le meilleur
contenu qu’on n’a jamais vu au Z Event.
J’avoue, j’ai dormi en live.
Bah en vrai, là je viens de me réveiller
et je suis plutôt en forme.
T’as vu ?
Je sens que j’ai fait une très bonne sieste.
Mais je te dis la vérité, je vais aller à l’hôtel,
je vais vraiment dormir après.
Il est beau à cette heure-ci, il est encore fringant.
Il est encore beau,
je ne comprends pas comment il fait.
Je viens de commencer, je n’ai pas encore bu mon café,
soyez indulgents s’il vous plaît.
Il faut les gens le matin, il faut les gens le soir.
Et nous, on est là, 7h du matin, on était prêts.
Et maintenant, il n’y a plus qu’à lancer le live
Kapu, 1 euro. Ferru, 27 euros.
Ici, ça donne directement, dès le début de journée,
j’espère que vous allez bien !
On est le dimanche matin, ils sont à deux doigts
de passer les 3 millions d’euros récoltés.
8500 balles, les gars !
D’un seul coup on est à 150 000 euros !
Ça va être les 3 millions ! Les 3 putains de millions !
Ouh, les 85 franchis sur l’ordinateur,
toute ma vie sur l’ordinateur ! Let’s go.
3 millions !
C’est insane. Bravo à toutes et tous.
Là, la journée s’annonce folle parce que,
aux 3 millions déjà,
ils n’ont pas encore rajouté la vente en ligne
des T-shirts du Z Event 2021
et ça représente tous les ans au moins plusieurs
centaines de milliers d’euros,
voire au moins un million d’euros,
donc c’est un chiffre énorme
qu’il faudra rajouter à la cagnotte.
Et en fin de journée, il y aura cette période
qu’on appelle le grand rush
où tous les streameurs vont inviter leurs vieweurs
à faire un maximum de dons
et en général, les gens, ils gardent beaucoup
de dons pour ce moment-là,
pour essayer de battre le record de l’année précédente.
Donc ça va être fou.
Vous voulez construire quelque chose ?
Vous voulez cueillir des baies ?
J’ai un petit… J’ai tout ce qu’il faut.
Zoome bien. Zoome mes pecs.
Les pecs. Les pecs, la salle.
♬ Ba di dou da di doui da di dou dou da da ♬
Voilà, vous l’aviez eu, “Didadou”,
la musique officielle, c’est pour bientôt.
On a atteint le goal des 150 000 euros
récoltés pour l’association.
Du coup, beh on part sur un petit tatoo
qui va me rappeler les World
qui ont été gagnées sur Warzone
et c’est inoubliable, ça, c’est incroyable.
Incroyable. Je suis…
C’est un événement de ouf.
Moi, je le vis à 200 %, tu vois, j’essaie de donner le max.
On verra jusqu’où on va aller,
mais je pense qu’il y a de fortes chances
que tous les records soient battus cette année.
Allez, plus que 100, plus que 100 !
Allez, allez !
Le mulet !!
C’est Kamel qui va avoir un mulet, là.
Kamel, il se fait un mulet ? Mais non.
Let’s go.
Je vais m’occuper de toi.
T’as mal, là, ou pas ? Ça va ?
Non, ça va, j’ai pas mal.
- Tiens.
- Non, non, mais jette derrière.
Ouech, là, on dirait,
on est dans les années 1973, là.
Oui, oui, c’est ça.
Là, pour l’instant, là, j’ai peur,
c’est un peu rude la tondeuse.
Oh là là là là. Welcome in France.
Hello, guys !
Record de France !
C’est vous ! C’est vous, le record français.
C’est vous, c’est pas moi.
J’ai jamais vu ça.
- T’es trop fort.
- Je suis choqué.
Le crack de la nation.
Mais tu sais que j’ai jamais vu ça.
Je suis choqué.
Mec, c’est incroyable.
C’est maintenant ou jamais, les reufs.
Donnez, donnez, donnez.
Merci Soricar pour les 90 balles !
Merci beaucoup !
Mon PC a crash à cause des dons, donc là,
les gens sont en train de réparer.
Mon PC… Mon PC marche plus à cause des dons, mec.
C’est les aléas.
Ça me fait une pause, en vrai, moi ça me met bien.
Je suis là… Non, mais je suis là depuis 10h.
Et puis de toute façon, en vrai,
ce qui est bien dans ce Z Event,
c’est que tu peux aller sur les live de tout le monde.
Même si ton live il marche pas, tant pis.
Moi, ça me fait plaisir. Bisous à vous.
Bientôt les 4 millions d’euros,
mesdames et messieurs !
C’est fait ! 4 millions d’euros !
C’est ouf ! Ça va si vite !
Moi, je dis : on peut essayer d’aller
taper les 6 ou 7 millions.
On va faire de notre mieux,
les gens aussi, je pense, donc on va bien voir.
Dernière ligne droite,
on va faire sortir tous les rats de France.
On va faire casquer tous les rats de France ce soir.
Comme vous le savez, chaque année
nous vendons des T-shirts pour le Z Event
et nous allons, puisqu’il est 20h, faire une première révélation de combien ces T-shirts ont rapporté.
Le chiffre ajouté à la cagnotte est de :
2 100 000 euros, mesdames et messieurs !
136 000 T-shirts vendus !
La cagnotte est donc à 6 617 000,
record de l’an dernier battu !
On va encore lever des dons jusqu’à 1h du mat’ !
Ouaiiiiis !
- Vous êtes prêts ?
- Ouaiiiiis !
C’est insane.
Je ne pensais pas qu’on dépasserait autant
le record de l’année dernière.
Et c’est pas fini, il nous reste 5 heures.
Il y a quelqu’un qui n’a pas pu être ici ce soir
et qui voulait venir au Z Event,
c’est Squeezie qui vient de faire un don
de 40 000 euros à Inoxtag, merci beaucoup à lui.
Merci beaucoup Eterlou pour les 7 euros,
merci beaucoup Simfury…
Merde, je suis mute !
Je suis mute !
L’armée des 2.
L’armée des 3.
Merci Salutcestmoi. 108 euros, Salutcestmoi !
7 millions !
C’est la folie, ils sont tous en train de se raid,
ça veut dire qu’ils sont tous en train de s’entraider
à remplir les cagnottes de chacun
et ça donne des scènes hyper émouvantes.
Quel bordel !
Allez ! Allez ! Allez !
Let’s go ! Let’s go !
Le rasoir ! Le rasoir !
La barbe ! La barbe !
Excusez-moi, 8 millions d’euros, bordel !
Ça y est, ils viennent de dépasser les 8 millions d’euros, maintenant.
Ça défile, donc il n’y a plus qu’à attendre le résultat final.
L’année dernière, elle était pas là, elle était pas sur place,
elle n’a pas pu venir.
Cette année, elle est là.
108 euros, il y a eu, 7 euros, 5 euros…
100 euros !
Oh là là, ils explosent la cagnotte.
Merci, Deujna, d’être venue. Merci beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci d’être venue, Deujna.
Continuez ! Elle part en mission humanitaire,
elle vient avec moi !
Tu viens avec moi en République centrafricaine
avec Action contre la faim ?
Elle vient avec moi !
C’est trop bien.
50 000 euros !
- Incroyable. Tiens, Deuj, reprends.
- 50 000 euros, on y va !
- T’as droit à un Strepsils en plus.
- Merci.
Et merci beaucoup, les gars,
ça me fait extrêmement plaisir d’être là.
Il y a tellement d’émotion,
je suis vraiment désolée de pleurer.
C’est du jamais vu, c’est du jamais vu.
9,6 millions, ça va à une vitesse incroyable.
On n’arrive pas à lire, ça va trop vite,
c’est débile, ça va beaucoup trop vite.
On va… On va… On va mourir.
Mesdames et messieurs, Chow1 fait
sa demande en mariage officiellement au Z Event…
Elle a dit oui !
Vive les mariés !
Merci beaucoup Kel.
Monté, 1 euro !
On est dans les dernières minutes de ce Z Event 2021,
tout l’argent que vous récoltez,
c’est extraordinaire. Merci !
Allez, Inox, fais-nous rêver, Inox !
1, 2, 3.
La chance me sourit !
On va tout éclater là maintenant tout de suite, les potes.
On a le dernier chiffre des T-shirts.
Après je vous laisse tranquilles.
Le chiffre qu’on va ajouter à la cagnotte
est de 565 000 euros, mesdames et messieurs !
On va le faire, les 10 millions !
Let’s go !
Plus que 15 minutes.
C’est la dernière ligne droite.
Tout le monde chez ZeratoR.
Chuuut.
C’est parti !
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1…
Ouaiiis !
Fais-moi un câlin avant de faire la signature…
Bien joué à toi.
- Allez.
- Toujours un monstre, merci d’exister.
Ça va, mon reuf ?
C’est incroyable,
c’est la meilleure édition de l’histoire.
Quel plaisir ! Il y a tout qui s’est passé mieux
que ça devait être prévu et moi, de mon côté,
avec ma communauté, on a des souvenirs de fous
qu’on a gardés de cet événement incroyable
et je pense que, là, après avoir vu ça,
on peut mourir tranquille.
C’est toi, le boss de la nuit, là.
Le boss de la nuit, là.
J’ai l’impression d’être en fin de soirée,
mais genre fin de soirée… fin d’after.
J’ai l’impression qu’il est 17h,
qu’on a teufé de 20h à 17h.
Avec mes habits, c’est accurate.
Tu sais, c’est un week-end comme les autres,
j’ai envie de te dire.
Un week-end comme les autres :
un petit 10 millions d’euros, quoi.
On verra ce qu’on fera la prochaine fois,
quoi, tout simplement.
Non, c’est incroyable, bien sûr.
- T’as l’air énervé.
- Non, bravo.
- Quand même, hein !
- Quand même.
Chaque année, je perds un peu.
Est-ce que ça repoussera ? Je sais pas.
Je suis si heureux.
On a la meilleure communauté du monde.
- Jijou !
- C’est extraordinaire, regardez.
Regardez, voilà, c’est beau.
Le divin chauve, le divin chauve !
C’est juste beau. Je suis trop heureux.
Merci, Laurent Blanc.
Extraordinaire.
Et merci, merci encore,
des milliards de fois, à vous tous,
puisqu’évidemment, nous, on streame,
on est bien beaux, voilà, mais vous avez tellement donné.
On a donné notre temps, OK,
mais vous avez tellement donné,
c’était extraordinaire, merci à tous.
Juste, je ne réalise pas encore,
je pense que dans trois, quatre jours, ça va redescendre
et je vais me faire : oh là là, c’était incroyable.
C’était mon meilleur Z Event.
Vraiment, cette année, c’était…
Sur les trois Z Event que j’ai faits au total,
c’était le meilleur.
Ah, mon frérot, quelle aventure de fou,
je suis complètement déglingué.
On a tout donné, et apparemment,
c’était je crois le Z Event le plus drôle à faire.
Je me suis trop amusé !
10 millions, c’est une dinguerie, je…
J’ai même pas les mots tellement les gens sont des rois.
Tenez…
Ils ont fait tomber leur couronne, tenez,
remettez votre couronne sur la tête,
tout le monde, tous ceux qui ont participé de près
ou de loin à cet événement.
Est-ce que tu penses que c’est un
des meilleurs moments de ta life ?
Frérot, je raconterai ça à mes enfants.
Tu vois ? Les gens, chez eux,
ils ont un cadre.
Moi, j’aurai un tableau NFT digital
avec que des clips du Z Event, frérot.
C’est comme ça !
Le turfu c'est comme ça.
je vais leur montrer.
Frérot, je m’en rappellerai à vie.
Oh, t’entends ma voix, là ?
J’ai jamais eu ma voix cassée de ma vie, carrément !
Je suis très ému et très fier d’avoir pu participer
à récolter autant d’argent
pour une ONG qui mérite, enfin, qui mérite
par son action et surtout pour les gens.
Et voilà, ça dit quelque chose, là, ça.
Nous, ça nous rend fiers, ça nous rend humbles
et j’espère que le message passe aussi
dans le cerveau de tout le monde
de se dire que beh ouais, la solidarité, ça a de l’avenir
et que le streaming, ça représente quelque chose.
C’est pas anodin du tout.
Quand je vois tous les gens qui sont différents
et qui viennent de milieux sociaux différents,
qui se regroupent et qui arrivent à faire ça tous ensemble,
avec des personnes qui sont derrière leur écran
et qui s’identifient à toutes ces personnes
qui sont si différentes,
bah moi, je trouve que c’est ça, l’unité, en fait.
J'ai été très agréablement surpris.
Les gens ont été fous, ils ont donné de partout.
10 millions, on a presque fait le double
de l’année dernière,
je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
qu’on pensait déjà impossible à battre,
on l’a pulvér’, on l’a pulvér’.
C’était fou et… je sais pas quoi dire.
Bien joué, frérot, c’était incroyable.
Félicitations, du coup.
Bien ouej, t'as été monstrueux.
T’as kiffé ton premier Z Event ?
Fantastique. Quelle énergie !
Tu peux être très fier de toi.
Merci, merci beaucoup.
10 millions.
C’est fini, putain, on l’a fait !
Je sais pas trop comment, énergie incroyable,
je suis mort. Regarde, filme ça.
Regarde ça. On n’a rien pu retenir.
Ah mec, bravo, encore bravo. Incroyable.
Ouah.
C’était un truc de ouf.
Clap de fin !
C’est dur. J’imagine même pas quitter
cette ambiance, gros.
T’as envie que ça dure.
Les trois jours sont passés à une vitesse…
Il y a tous les copains avec qui
on joue de loin qui sont là.
Quitter ça, mec, ça va être dur.
Ça va être dur.
Bravo. Merci.